smashing past believing in ghosts it's
better than believing in god
hey everyone we're the cast of peacocks
queer as full and today we're going to
be playing smash or pass
we'll be debating some hot topics and
explain our takes all right
let's do it smash or pass making the
first move
smash smash for sure i love taking
control yeah you have a lot of people in
new orleans can attest to that oh my god
that's not true
performing at a drag show
well i mean smash okay i feel like that
one was set up i would pass oh actually
you know what i actually did that in new
orleans so smash wow so brave hashtag
mask could never love flip-flops
at an airport hard smash i love a dirty
floor all over my feet no [ __ ] that
pass pass not a chance i don't even own
a pair of flip-flops you don't have like
a pair of rainbow flip-flops no but i
will strut through tsa with these
periods
so personally i would not wear
flip-flops but i would smash someone who
would wear flip-flops because life is
long and
hopefully so are they pineapple on pizza
smasher pack oh smash it's so good and
anyone that thinks opposite is
trash
okay
it's a smash that's magic that's crazy
these topics just get hotter and hotter
climate change
a partner whose mom still does their
laundry i mean that's hard to say
people's moms still want to feel needed
in some kind of way when they're out of
the house and sometimes it's just a
matter of laziness i have to say smash
and pass
situational does your mom do your
laundry no okay i don't care who does
your laundry as long as it's done
sleeping naked smash of course please
like clothes restrictive
smash every night so there you have it
team sleep naked we heard it here first
folks that's us in case you were
wondering dating your siblings ex
major pass um because also my siblings
are
children would i do that
absolutely
someone whose job title is entrepreneur
on their dating profile oh smash or pass
why i don't know i just like i guess
maybe not smash i love i love someone
with a dream i feel like that's a riot
moment i'm not on raya personally but i
think you are so what happened once upon
a time uh i've actually deleted all my
dating apps
so i would cleaning house okay wow
sometimes you gotta do it yeah but i
would definitely outcast yeah i mean
it's definitely better than creative
director we're in a creative director
epidemic and everyone's a creative
director now and right gone to my head i
don't even know what that means and i
don't think they do either kissing with
your eyes open
smash also situational also situational
it could either be teetering on creepy
or like really hot yeah yeah
i vote it's usually both and you know
what not mad at it at all i'm here for
it yeah
yeah i do it
yes
using dating apps
and i've seen you on some so i guess
wait what
isn't it my turn using dating apps smash
your pass smash i've seen you on a
dating app we've we've matched on a
dating app famously got rid of yours i
famously got ready why so i chose to
pass on dating apps my hope is that i'll
meet someone in the wild because that
sounds exciting well that's hot
privilege when you're hot enough you can
meet someone like at whole foods arguing
over the last like chia seed pudding so
that can happen my wrong come dreams a
date who doesn't know the difference
between there there and there it's so
situational that's me so
smash
there's so many hard things for people's
brains to catch up on but you know what
i'm gonna just pass for now you gotta
draw the line somewhere and grammar
is one of them okay but if you're hot
it's fine you know what i mean like
i for one don't care if you have good
grammar all you have to do is get they
them right and we're set period
sliding into dm smash
smash i mean how else do you meet people
these days whole foods right fighting
over the chia seed pudding but again
that's hot privilege so you understand
so you think i'm hot clapping when the
plane lands oh
all the people that that do that need
help
pass
why do i feel like you'd clap with the
plane oh my god that is the biggest read
you've ever said to me welcome miami
everybody
so how do you feel about having a
instagram account for a pet that's
called i don't have a personality and i
need to fill in the blanks by having a
pet
couples
halloween costumes i don't know what the
air quotes is because major smash no i
would literally that's embarrassing
again that's called i don't have a
personality so my relationship needs to
fill in the blanks going through your
partner's phone if they left it unlocked
historically smash but because i'm
healed pass oh dave i'm so proud of you
therapy works major facetiming
instead of texting
this is a read because smash that's all
i do i like to phone call i'm like
basically a boomer oh no you're
basically a serial killer like every
time ryan calls me we end up talking for
like two and a half hours yeah because i
have some things i need to say to you
listen babe i don't get it why aren't
you dating i'm a taipei virgo and i like
to fix
i'm a gemini and i like to run smash
your pass date a co-worker a major pass
50 shades of pass
the first shade has been there done that
no thank you
i have one last question for you what's
that smash your pass watching queer as
folk on peacock
smash baby smash
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you